Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking.
I'm a cybernetic organism.
Living
episode is brought to
you by a cent protein.
I am really excited about this discovery.
I became aware of these guys when I
found out that they'd spent five years
trying to manufacture a better version
of whey protein and the result is
something called native proteins,
which represents cleaner, pure,
less processed protein.
So here's a mini tutorial.
There are only a handful of companies
worldwide that can extract native proteins
directly from milk.
Traditional whey protein.
What you've probably bought before
is a byproduct of making cheese.
So a company must have the resources,
knowhow and a large customer
base to invest in extracting
proteins directly from
the milk without the ability to also
profit from the associated cheese.
That means that net net is
native proteins are super rare.
So a scent is the only us based company
that offers native proteins both way and
my seller casein directly to the consumer.
They're able to do that because the
parent company Laprino is a huge cheese
manufacturer.
They've been filtering proteins for
more than 30 years and there are few
important things to take away from this.
Number one, zero artificial ingredients.
That is a solid claim. It's much
stricter than all natural. Number two,
they've done extensive testing,
so the chocolate which I've been using
after every workout and also in the
mornings was finalized after 282
recipes were vetted and the perhaps most
important,
I talked about less processed.
They avoid steps like bleaching and
this is important to understand so it's,
it's a very big deal but hasn't
yet caught on for sports nutrition.
Traditional whey proteins are a byproduct
of cheese making. Like I mentioned,
many of the proteins are therefore
orange in color because they were sourced
from say cheddar cheese production because
companies can't sell orange powders,
vanilla or strawberry, they have
to bleach the proteins, wipe this,
harms the proteins and leaves trace
amounts of bleach in the product.
That is no window, no good infant
formula companies, for instance,
a banned the use of bleached proteins
already in their products and that is why
a sense parent company,
Leprino foods is the number one
supplier of protein to infinite formula
companies. So all that said, if you want
cleaner, pure, less processed protein,
which I certainly do and I'm
really excited to be using
this protein and I just
ran out of chocolate, so I
need another bag, check it out.
Go to a cent protein.com
forward slash Tim, that's a s,
c e n t protein.com sent protein.com
forward slash Tim and you can receive 20%
off of your entire order. If you want
a quick 25 gram dose to start your day.
For instance, you're following
slow carb diet or after workout.
This is a great option.
They also have my seller Casein,
which is slower release and you
can check that out. So take a look,
go to a cent protein.com forward slash
Tim
this episode is brought
to you by four sigmatic,
founded by the Genius Fin's
who lit the Internet on fire.
And you may have heard
of their mushroom coffee,
which features Chaga and lion's mane,
which has taken Silicon Valley by storm.
I use it pretty much every day,
either that or he chaga,
which is decaf as a separate version,
and I use both of these primarily
for focus and productivity.
They just get you going let
you up like a Christmas tree.
So definitely check it out.
People are always asking me what I use
for cognitive enhancement and for right
now this is the answer. I try to
force this on all of my house guests.
It is a hell of a thing if
I have employees or people
come over who are working
on projects with me,
I always try to feed it to them because
I'm going to get the limitless effect
and get a lot more out of them.
The first time I mentioned this product
and four sigmatic on the podcast,
their product sold out
in less than a week,
so you may want to check them out soon.
If you're listening to this and
the coffee tastes like coffee,
it takes just seconds to
prepare with hot water.
And oddly enough,
only includes 40 milligrams of caffeine,
so it has less than half of what
you'd get in a regular cup of coffee.
I don't get any jitters, acid reflux
or any stomach burn, any of that.
It's very unusual and very,
very cool.
So if you don't like caffeine,
they also offer very strong,
but caffeine free mushroom elixirs, which
I will sometimes have in the evening.
I find Chaga specifically to be very,
very grounding and earthy.
So that is another option. And I have
a cupboard full of their products, uh,
at the moment, which is right
around the corner of my kitchen.
You can try something. You can
try a sample pack, which is great.
Also right now by going to
foursigmatic.com forward slash Tim,
that's foursigmatic, F, O, U R S, I g,
m a t I c.com forward slash Tim and use
the Code Tim Tim to get 20% off of your
first order and they're
not that expensive. Anyway.
If you are in the experimental mindset,
I do not think you'll be
disappointed to trauma.
You sexy little minx. Oh,
stop it. This is Tim Ferriss.
Welcome to another episode of the Tim
Ferriss show and a parent's sorry.
Have to define minx for your children
and listening in the car during the drive
to school, but so it goes.
That's how the cards have fallen.
It is my job to deconstruct world class
performers on the show and we do that in
many different areas.
Whether they come from say the military,
from entertainment, from
research, from sports.
You've can spot common patterns
and my is to tease out the details,
the philosophies,
the habits that you can use.
This episode features Bill Rasmussen
at bill underscore ESPN on Twitter.
I'll keep this short.
He gives where we want to jump right into
a bill is the founder of ESPN and the
creator of the 24 hour programming
cycle that all networks use today.
I was really excited to be able
to sit down with them and uh,
we really recorded a lot.
We recorded three hours material and only
one hour was used for my new TV show,
which I'm going to get to in a second.
And this podcast episodes
is almost entirely new.
Exclusive content that did not
appear on the TV show. The TV show,
if you want to check it out,
is fearless with less in parentheses
because the goal is not to be fearless,
but to learn to fear less.
Where I interview people like this world
class performance about how they've
overcome doubt, fear, and
made their toughest decisions.
You can watch the entire first episode
with illusionist and endurance artists,
David Blaine for free@att.net
forward slash fearless.
I highly recommend it.
Check it out. It's awesome.
And he does a lot on stage and
to watch all of the episodes,
there are 10 of them. You can go to
tim.blog, forward slash fearless.
Just type it all out,
no proxies.
tim.blog/fearless and you can select
your option if you're a cord cutter.
If you use computers instead of TVS,
you can just click on direct TV now and
all of the packages have it to see can
choose the cheapest one or the free
trial to take a look. And that is it.
So without further ado,
please enjoy my wide ranging
conversation with Bill Rasmussen.
I'm your host Tim Ferris
stage.
We will be deconstructing world class
performers of all types to uncover the
specific tactics and strategies
they've used, overcome doubt,
tackle heart decisions,
and ultimately succeed by show of hands.
How many people here wait for say the
morning paper to get their sports scores?
It's a big fat zero.
How many of you can remember
when television wasn't
available? 24 hours a day.
Anyone of my generation are a little
bit older. I've got a few hands.
And when I say Bristol,
Connecticut, what do you think of
after meeting my guest tonight?
You'll associated with one thing
and that is sports against all odds.
Heat set out to change the
course of television and
the status quo as we know it
and in the process he created one of the
most iconic and recognizable brands in
the world. Please welcome the
founder of ESPN, Bill Rasmussen.
[inaudible].
What was your grandfather like?
Describe for us your relationship
with your grandfather.
He was literally a dyed in the wool,
a white sox fan.
He took me to Kaminski
Park when I was very,
very young and I can remember he lived,
if you're familiar with Chicago,
35th Street,
it was 35th and shields is where the
Comiskey park was and he lived at 33rd and
bell.
I can remember these details like I
can't believe that they're there and he
would walk me to the street car and say,
now when all of the people start
getting off here at the Ballpark,
like I would know where
the ballpark was there.
It is right in front of me and I
can remember finding out early,
and this was in the early 1940s
the ballpark would open if it
was one o'clock game and it was,
they opened the gates at 11 o'clock in,
my goal was always to
be there to be one day,
be the first one in the ballpark and
one day I did do it and my grandmother
would give me a sandwich and a little
coke bottle with those little green
bottles. I would take that off
under the rug, out of the streetcar,
a nickel or whatever it was to go on
the street car and get off Comiskey Park
and being there one day they were worried.
Red sox and white sox played
a doubleheader first game
when 13 innings and the
second one went to the
bottom of the ninth.
Both games were seven to six and it took,
you know,
half a day to play all that.
I didn't leave.
I was there from two hours before the
first pitch to the end of the second game
and that my grandfather allowed us how
at that point I became an official white
sox fan. So anything allowed
as long as it's white sox,
as long as it was the one lane as well.
And it was really, it's only a few blocks.
Yes,
I you're reciting these statistics.
The,
for one of the first thoughts that jumped
to mind was you'd make a really good
intelligence officer and then I
thought of something that I had heard,
which was you played war games as a kid.
Am I making this up or did you have,
yeah, we used to, well, everybody
did. Okay. Every, I mean,
when 1941 occurred,
I was in the fourth grade and before,
I think before Christmas,
we're all talking about everybody.
Everybody in America was talking about
we all have to be together though, or no,
right. Left up, down or anything.
We were all on the same,
same team and at the
early part of the war,
before they started saying,
you couldn't do this.
I can remember my father's shirts come
back from the cleaners or the piece of
cardboard in pretty much like they do
today I suppose in some some places and we
used to draw whatever we want it to do.
If I was going to be a master sergeant
for the games the next day we would draw
it on a board, then color
with crayons, you know,
red and green and blue or whatever it was,
cut them out.
And with rubber bands we put them on our
arms and off we go the next day to do
whatever battle we had decided we were
doing and we did that basically all
through the war.
It was kind of crazy,
but we had to start using
other things because uh,
hangars and cardboard, we're
all confiscated. We went out.
Oh yeah, they had everything went to the
war effort. We, we picked up newspapers,
everything went and was, we didn't use,
they didn't use the word recycle then,
but that's what it was. They
were recycling and producing
anything. It's pretty,
pretty cool.
Do you remember where you were
when you heard about Pearl Harbor?
Absolutely.
What a picture.
55 south Mount Vida Avenue
and Columbus manner,
just south of 90 to today.
Back then 95th street was highway 12
and 20 on the south side. Chicago,
two lanes, one in each direction. Today
is 12 lanes, six in each direction,
but my happened and my father got
us all around the radio and we sat.
We sat literally on the living
room floor watching the radio,
listening to news reports, and we were
not unique. Happened all across America.
Also, if we flash forward just a little
bit to say high school and look at your
experience in high school, you played
baseball. Did you try any other sports?
Oh yeah.
I tried football once because my father
encouraged me to do that because I was
really fast. Had football, go
for it. Yeah, well I was so fast.
One afternoon I intercepted a pass.
You wouldn't even,
maybe you would understand some of
the football technology of the day.
We had defensive halfbacks and we had,
we didn't have all of these white
outs and slots and safe with them with
different things.
Anyway,
I was a defensive halfback intercept
of the past and because I was so fast,
I went around very quickly. I didn't see
anybody in front of me and I thought,
what a great,
this is really going to be great.
Touchdown was insight and
I woke up under the bench.
Sweet. What happened?
Somebody was faster than I was
and when they were
faster than I was and I,
when it's not expected and you get
tackled from behind, I was literally late,
light out, game over football,
career over that was it done.
So did you, was it your choice to end
the football or did you decide, okay,
happen
and with baseball and,
but then I did find out playing
baseball one day in a practice.
We were just doing an inner
squad game and I turned around,
you know what the cardinal
rule is in baseball?
Never ever take your eye off the
ball. Right. And if you're playing in,
never ever take your eye off the ball.
I went like this one time and
turned back and that's all it goes.
And as I turned back,
I get hit right in the face of the baby.
And maybe that's why. Well,
no, we're not going to go away.
That's why I look this way today. I
think you look fine. I don't know.
I think my nose is more quick.
The nearest maybe I got hit by a
baseball and don't remember it.
Actually I didn't actually know I did.
This is true because I
remember my first day, uh,
little league tryouts in deep in left
field fly ball right in the middle of the
face.
That was the end of my baseball career.
That would be embarrassing
for an outfielder. Oh,
it was embarrassing for anything fielder,
especially as whatever I was a third or
fourth grader is the runt of the litter
as it was. And now I have lack of
hand eye coordination to go with it.
It was terrible.
Uh,
tell me about a little
bit about high school. Uh,
in doing research,
I read about an essay contest,
the ended up sending you
ultimately to me suppose the,
the president or soon to be president.
Can you, could you describe that for us?
And I was a junior in high school in 1948.
Started my junior year that September
and there was a Chicago Sun Times,
had an essay contest for all students.
That six of from the city,
we're going to be chosen to go to a
president, Harry Truman, his inauguration.
That was the famous selection where the
Chicago Tribune and put out the headline,
Dewey wins.
And then Truman held up the paper the
next day and his picture was in there
holding up the picture of the newspaper.
And of course do we didn't win. But uh,
the deal was we'd write
an essay and so on.
And my father decided that I could
write an essay on becoming a lawyer.
I was going to become a
lawyer and I must've done a
really persuasive job on why
I want it to be a lawyer because I was
one of the six winners and we got to go
to a Washington, we got to sit
on the, the capital, whatever.
I'm not sure what they call it,
but up there with all the dignitaries,
a senator Dayas or whatever
it might be. Well, you know,
it's where the senators and
the representatives were
included in that. And uh,
there was six of us and watched Harry
Truman take his oath of office in 1949.
I got this, watch them take
the actual, uh, we were,
we were right there in 1949 and
we went that night. Of course,
they have all these different parties
and one of the things that stands out,
we were all 16 year old kids.
So we were chaperoned everywhere we went
and we were standing at the Shoreham
hotel and I turned to my left and General
Omar Bradley was standing right there
and he'd put his hands, said,
hi, how are you? You know,
what are you doing here in the General?
Omar Bradley was a,
an icon to the people of that
era that was unknown. And I,
I've never forgotten that.
So we were able to maintain your
composure through all of that. I mean,
you get flown to the president or it's
going to be president being sworn in.
Then you turn,
you see an icon on the other side.
Were you able to maintain your
composure through all of that?
Yeah, I think I was just numb
through it all. I didn't even,
she didn't even register, you know. No,
I mean obviously I knew who he
was and then I was very, uh,
we were all very honored to be selected.
So you get to college and were there any
particular teachers? They're there too.
I've read about a history and Econ,
but were there any particular
teachers we had a large impact on you?
Um, the, uh,
the one professor in economics financial
organization had investment was a,
he was the head of the
economics department,
Doctor Joe me and he was an interesting
channel one to say the least.
And if you weren't paying
attention and he had a great arm,
he should've been a shortstop.
I don't think these schools
exist this way today,
but we used to have blackboard all the
way across the front of the room and all
the way down the side of the room.
And he would start at the class
over here at the left hand side,
putting things up and talking
and on and on, lecturing.
And his suit would get all
covered with chalk dust and so on.
And then he turned around out
of nowhere and he'd say, Tim,
what about whatever the question was,
if you didn't get it,
he'd take that eraser and he'd hit you
in the forehead, hit you in the shoulder,
and then your mark was, if you came out
of the class with no chalk marks on it,
who was a successful afternoon.
And I can also,
just to put it in a little perspective,
I remember the day the
Dow Jones average hit 3000
and you know how we used to get,
there was no online follow button.
Minute by minute he would bring
in after the market closed, the,
the Wall Street Journal would publish
everything in printed form and he would
bring that in the next day. And that's
how we learned about the stock market.
Crazy stuff.
And uh, was there another
professor who did reenactments?
Oh yeah, Andrew Crandall. Dr
Crandall. He was actually,
he was a noted civil war
expert in the country.
And every year he would,
the only place big enough to
hold his lectures if you will,
was um, what's the name,
Mitchell Hall, the uh,
chemistry laboratory with all of the,
the theater types aits and down front.
And he would set up huge
tables and reenact the battle
of Gettysburg or whatever
it was. And he had little, it
was like kids toys. Really.
He was so engrossed and he too, he would
start off with a shirt and tie and coat.
And before long as the war,
as the battle progressed,
raging bull comes up and they
were standing room only lectures.
It was just amazing.
People wanted to see because
he was entertaining but
so knowledgeable about the
civil war.
And He created an awareness in so many
students about that period in our history
that I can remember it very,
very vividly. He was a,
he was an enthusiastic and a very,
very knowledgeable person about it all.
And we talked about
Pickett's charge or Robert E.
Lee doing this and grant doing it.
I mean it was, it was incredible.
I never missed come on four years,
I seem to recall.
And you can,
you can shoot this down as
a figment of my imagination.
A stint as you had a lot of different
gigs and part time gigs that seem as a
collection to have really informed
what you did later at the ESPN.
Did you not have some experiences?
A weatherman?
Oh yeah. Oh, is that fun? And you,
and you started inserting things into
the weather. Well, what, what happened?
It's coming. Bear with us. So Mike,
let's talk about being, yeah,
yeah. I, well first of all,
you had to understand why I ended up,
why I even ended up at the station
talking about being a weatherman. I, um,
lived in Amherst, Massachusetts and
there were, you have to remember now,
this is in 1964,
1965.
We had two stations once NBC
station when ABC Station,
that's all a television there was. And
the entire western part of Massachusetts,
the NBC station had news,
weather and sports from 11 to 11 or
seven to seven 30 and 11 to 1130.
The ABC Station at 11 o'clock just
did 15 minutes news and signed off.
So I said,
I'm not going to get the guy's job at
the one that does 11 hours a half hour at
11 why don't I go talk to the station
managers at the ABC station and tell him
he needs a sports show? It's
part of the confidence, I guess.
And so I went and met him, call for an
appointment. He said, sure, come on down.
He said, what is it you want
to do? I said, well, the
other guys are doing sports.
You should be doing sports.
Ah, we don't want under sports.
So we talked a while and he
said, well, all right. All
right, I'll pay a $10 a show.
I had to drive 40 miles to get
there. 20 miles, 40 miles round trip.
So taking that loss.
So it's a net loss. So,
and you can start Monday. Okay,
well I knew I could do sports.
So I get down there and I'm walking in
the door on Monday, whatever it was,
the 3rd of January, the 5th of January.
And he said, I've changed my mind.
I have you.
What do you mean you've changed your,
I thought I'd fired and I wasn't fired.
He said, you're going to do the weather.
We're not going to do sports. You're
going to do the weather. I said,
I don't know anything about whether
shoveling snow doesn't qualify you to,
you know, he said, here's the
way we're going to do the,
whether you call Bradley field,
talk to the Noaa,
the national weather people at Bradley.
Feel calm around 10 30 find out what
the world looks like around, you know,
this general area.
Scratch a few things.
We didn't have clay strong nines and all
of these kinds of things back then we
had a grease pencil and a
whiteboard and write something down.
Draw a picture of Springfield if you
like or Massachusetts and just say it's
going to be 68 degrees in rain tomorrow.
That's,
that's all people are going to
get. So I can, and I can remember,
and just to digress for a second visit,
some nine or 10,000 live shows a goal.
But this was the very first one.
I can remember when they said one minute
I turned around and put my back to the
camera and the sweat running down the
center of my back. And I remember saying,
why am I subjecting myself to this?
And they turned said, you know,
10 seconds, five, four. I turned around
and I decided I really like this.
This is pretty good stuff.
I'm going to it to be telling people
about the weather. And I decided just,
I had followed the Springfield Indians
hockey team in the American hockey league
and the Boston Bruins and the rangers,
everybody in the area. So I said,
well, we're going to do is we're going to
find the weather from different cities,
especially where the
team was playing and say,
tonight it's a 32 degrees in Pittsburgh
and the white snow falling on the
Indians won three to two and I
would just write three to two.
So I thought,
well this will get me fired for sure.
So you didn't ask this was a forgiveness,
not permission. Oh yeah, forgive. Oh,
it's much easier to ask
forgiveness. So, uh,
that's what we did.
And the next day I didn't see the
general manager didn't say anything.
So the next night I did a couple of
more scores and the next day I found out
some people call the station and
said, you know, this new sports idea.
And whether they thought it was a, they
thought it was, I guess it was a plan Gig,
but it wasn't. It just happened.
And grand collaborative innovation.
And then the
gentleman at the NBC station was promoted,
went down to Charlotte, North Carolina,
and before he left, because he had,
obviously we had met along the
way because competitors do that.
And he recommended me for that job and
in the things happen for a good reason
kind of thing.
I went up to that station and I was only
doing the weather and the sports for
about four months.
And then I went to the other station,
the NBC station started doing sports.
And it happened to be in the year that
Mohammed Ali and Sonny Liston fought.
And Louis did main pick fight and
his headquarters were in Chicopee,
Massachusetts.
And I was the guy able to go down and I
met him back then and we met each other
several times after that.
But you never know.
I mean here was a station
that wasn't doing something.
I talked him into something I guess or
they decided they were going to do it and
then the other guy leaves and I get
his job and all of a sudden listen.
And back then it was Cassius clay.
We're going to have this big
fight and I can tell you,
and people who know Cassius
Clay, you know, pretty bum,
bombastic person,
and he was,
we had a lunch in one day
and he was his usual self.
And then he said he was going upstairs.
It was a long way from where his
training camp was to the station.
So I decided to stay there and I
just sat in the lobby and an hour.
So after lunch I,
I just kind of dozing off waiting for
the four o'clock press conference and I
sense somebody sitting down over and is
Cassius clay. I ain't doing, what do you,
you know, we'd said that we
talked for probably an hour,
normal tones just to just a great guy. We
were just, it was a young guy obviously,
and we were,
he said,
well I guess I better go up and we're
going to do this four o'clock writing.
And I was, they didn't call it that,
but I was called the question asker,
the pool announcer.
I was going to ask all the questions
and he was going to answer for every,
for everybody. So as I'd seen little
wine. Yeah. Good. Looking forward to it.
A few minutes later, white
suit, white shoes, white shirt,
white tie, big. Everybody. Wow.
Here he come. He came down,
he looked right to me.
Like he had never even seen me before.
Did his press conference with all
the usual bombast that he did.
And I've never forgotten that. And I
saw many years later and he remembered,
he put on a stage. So it on and he put
on a show. He was, but he was, he was,
he was quite a guy.
I was privileged to meet him.
What's most, what were the most memorable
aspects of that encounter to you?
The fact that he could turn it on,
turn it off that way,
turn it on and turn it off in his
personality. And he was really, I mean,
he talked just like you and I are
talking. It wasn't, it wasn't, it wasn't,
I'm the champ and you're just a guy here
in Massachusetts. It wasn't that at all.
And I never forgot that.
And I saw many,
many years later and uh,
it was the same and it was the same way.
You mentioned something just a minute ago,
the things happen for a reason.
Is that a core belief of yours, the
things happen for a reason? Has It always?
Yeah. Sometimes. Maybe we make it
happen and sometimes it just happens.
If you had to say teach, let's just
call it, you can pick the grade,
ninth grade class,
college class doesn't really matter.
To help students develop confidence.
What,
how would you approach that or
how would you even think about it?
Are there any, you know, a lot of
people ask me that question and I'm not,
this is going to sound odd.
I'm not sure I'm qualified to do that
in the form of a college curriculum,
but if I can somehow transmit that
belief and the feeling of success and
positive approach to things that you
have to have and be able to take the
negatives and get past them.
And I don't know how you'd do that in
a college curriculum, but it's, I just,
you know, whether it's stealing bases
or selling products or whatever.
As I said earlier,
I think that when somebody says no,
they've made the mistake and I don't,
I don't know how you,
I don't know how I would do that.
The other leg of the table,
it seems as advertising,
so you shortly, while, I don't
know if it was shortly after,
but after getting the NCAA to commit,
we were a little ahead of that little
ad. Yeah, we were. We were floating them.
They were one of the,
so we told them who we were talking to.
We didn't tell them we had them.
This is a well known beer company,
Spas. It is. And so can you tell
us a little bit about how that was,
was that happening concurrently?
Was that another ball in the air?
That was happening in early January.
Okay. We had hired as an advertiser Bush.
Yeah.
We had hired a gentleman from Connecticut,
general insurance to be
our general sales manager.
He was the general sales manager.
They're like the sports idea and I said,
we have to,
obviously the obvious choice is Anheuser
Busch largest sports advertiser in the
world. Then and maybe today, I don't know,
but we had a very specific
plan to take them.
That sounds odd when I say all these
other vagaries that we're just juggling,
but we had a very specific
plan. We decided that if we
could get eight sponsors,
a 2 million,
$760,000 a year,
that would finance total of the sum
total of the eight sponsors? No, no.
Total eight times. So it'd be
20 $20 million. Got It. Got It.
So we, uh, went down to New York,
got invited down to Darcy
Mcmanus and the vice president,
Jane Patrola was his name and
he listened and he was a trig.
He has to be intrigued. It's his business
sports business, Budweiser. He said,
I'll take it to the brewery, I'll get
back to you a couple of days later.
And we went back down
to New York and he said,
I've been to the brewery
will give you a $500,000.
That's the first sign we ever had of
any money coming our way are 9,000 have
gone out the door. My family and friends
had gone out the door, k a suite of,
puts the money in and we were, we were
running on just the first black ink,
like real influences.
Yeah.
And Bob and I looked at each other
and we shook our heads and said,
and this just, I was sitting right
the way I'm sitting with you, Tim.
And as you know in New York out windows,
they're advertising things
on the sides of buildings,
on the front of buildings
and mark keys and everywhere.
And it just so happened over jeans.
Left shoulder was a big ad
for Miller Miller high life.
And I looked at Bob and he looked at me
and I took my eyes from gene and I said,
we can't accept that and we were
going to have to pursue other avenues.
And I just looked over that way. And
he said, before you do that, he knew,
he knew what ad was out the window.
He said, let me have an exact word,
let me have another go at the brewery.
He called a couple days later and he said,
I'll tell you what, nobody's ever
done this and cable television,
we'll give you a million,
$380,000 and let's go.
And that's the way it was.
So we had 1,000,380 committed before
we had the programming committee.
And then before we had the financing
committed, which is kind of, you know,
when all the eggs are running and it
doesn't make any difference which order
they come in just to get them home.
What were some of the
more say, costly, uh,
decisions or missteps that
you guys had early on? Um,
there had to been something I
would have been, yeah, well we did,
we did Canadian football.
We tried to do some,
we tried to do a lot of
different things with different,
we always tried to overreach.
And even to this day, uh,
just a couple of years ago, I was
in, uh, Dallas talking to ESPN radio,
which by the way is now the biggest
radio network. You know, it's just crazy.
Uh,
and I asked that very same question about
what happens in what are the mistakes?
And this fellow had worked
for ABC and so I said,
what's the difference between the
two same market? He worked for ABC,
now he's working for ESPN
because obviously they were
all bought by Disney and
they're all in the same
house, so to speak. He said,
ABC always sent out
directives to us saying,
don't rock the boat. We're doing well
in this market. We're doing well here.
We're doing all these, they don't rock
the boat. He, ESPN on the other hand says,
try everything that pops into your
mind. If it works, great. If it doesn't,
forget it and move on.
Two totally different approaches.
Sounds like the bill Rasmussen got into
life. That's like the mantra, right?
Well, but eh, but if we think about that,
how discouraging it would
be to your employees to say,
I don't want you to come in and telling
me anything. He might have a greater,
I don't want to hear your great idea
after you've given them an opportunity to
work for you. Now you don't want to hear
from him. So encourage everybody in,
but let's do it all. And if
you met someone, if he mess up,
nobody's going to shoot you and there's
no debtor's jail. There's no, you know,
no guillotine. This
isn't whatever. And uh,
I thought that was interesting from them.
They've tried a number of things.
We did a thing with, uh,
not when I was there,
but with a cell phones.
When they first came in,
there was some gigantic program when
they were testing it with kids of all the
employees and everything else.
And it didn't work.
So they just moved on.
Of course,
they've changed that around a little bit
now with streaming and everything else
in cell phones today of course a little
different than they were 10 years ago.
Did we even have cell phones 10 years ago?
I don't even remember.
We did. They just, they were closer
to the Gordon Gekko. Yeah, Rick.
Uh, okay. But yes, we did have the,
what I'd love to do because
we're talking about,
of course ESPN arguably your
best known for that. Uh,
but to sort of bring it
full circle for a second,
we're going to bring out a prop.
It's not really a prop. This is,
this is a real, it's a
real thing. A real thing.
I don't want to spoil the surprise,
so we're going to get that.
That's going to come out.
But I thought we might do if the team in
the back can bring up the then and now
some of the stats,
because you mentioned radio and I just
thought just to put this in perspective
for people starting with Irish hurling
and juggling five different balls,
telling everyone,
each person that everyone else is in
until ultimately you get them all in.
I think it's pretty staggering when
you look at the before and after and
if you, so I'm not going to read
all of these stats for you guys.
We can see subscribers and 1.3
million to more than 90 million,
80 employees,
more than 8,000 than one
acre just in Bristol alone,
223 radio,
none to 20 million and that's not
even counting the publishing arm.
No huge magazine and everything else.
Yeah,
it's an amazing their subscriber fees.
This is a staggering number to me.
We started off asking for a penny,
one penny at it, would you pay me,
Tim if I came to and I said, Tim,
give me a penny day, 30 cents a month
and you can watch sports 24 hours a day.
I can give you a penny a day. Does
that sound good? That sounds good. Cut.
Turned down and got left out. As a matter
of fact, just to digress for a moment,
one of those people that I said, you
could make money doing this. I said,
not only that,
we're to give you a local availabilities.
I got this funny look like what's
a local availability? Yeah,
I was going to ask you. Yeah, well, what
we're going to do is answer ESPN. Whoa.
Pause, and you can put in a
local sponsored Joe's pizza,
somebody Sam's Toyota or whatever in
your market and your telecast. Nuke him.
Advertise. Oh, you know what the answer
was? Why would I want to do that?
I kind of did just what you
said like this, what? He said,
I'd have to hire somebody to go sell.
I said,
here's how I did it.
Very this,
that was probably rude that
I shouldn't have done this,
but I did it cause it's a knee jerk
reaction to me. So said, here's an idea.
He sells a hundred he keeps tending.
You get 90
oh well maybe we can talk again.
Well now today,
back then cable,
the cable systems didn't make much money
advertising today it's a multibillion
dollar business as you know,
they just make all kinds of money.
So let's,
let's bring in what I've mentioned before.
So if we could bring in what we have here,
I'll do my best to hold this in pieces.
Let me fall apart.
Pieces may fall apart. He tell us
what this is please. This is a,
this is the latest and
greatest love of at the time,
a third baseman in 1947
this is my original baseball
glove in high school when I
was at high school, Sophomore.
And if you can see it,
I don't try and put your hand in there,
Tim, as if you were playing third base.
I'll be the guy who destroys
it on national television.
Can you imagine catching balls with that?
And it was,
that was not the easiest thing in the
world. This looks like cookie monster.
Now you know,
here's another baseball fans of the day.
This was what you had to do
when the evening was over.
You turned around and you through your
glove back onto the outfield grass.
Major Leagues did it. We
did it. Say that again.
I didn't know this all virtually all
through the first half century when the
infielders came off the
field or the outfields,
they never brought their glove
in with them into the dugout.
They left him the third basement
drop as long the fall line,
shortstop and throw his in short leftfield
second baseman in short right field.
Why nobody?
I mean today there's so if there's a,
I dunno,
a clean expos across field time out and
you have to get out and clean in here.
They were just littering the field with
their own gloves. But what amazes me,
I found this in some storage.
Obviously this was absolutely the most
expensive thing I had ever had in my life
to do with baseball at that point in 19,
it was to be the spring of 1947
and I look at the gloves today.
Softball gloves are so much
better than this. And uh, I don't,
I don't know how we ever, I don't know
how everybody didn't have about a 500, uh,
feeling average because how we
caught things. I don't know.
It's pretty amazing though,
and I'm really pleased with that because
it does bring back lots of memories.
Did you collect anything as a kid? I
what? Did you collect anything as a kid?
Did you clicked? No statistics.
Statistics. I was into,
we had a, we had a little board game
where you spun an Arrow and it wouldn't,
you know,
they sent out,
I think maybe it was one of the bubble
gum companies that pay this little game
and whoever they had on their cards,
they'd make the all star team for the
National Union American Legion that you're
gonna need to spin any, make up games
and percentages and to do all that.
I was forever drawing little things.
I remember my father worked at the Ford
aircraft engine division and during the
war and he brought me home,
uh,
what did they call a
mimeographed scorecards and
I would use those scorecards
and play a game and eight or nine or
10 minutes and fill out a scorecard and
it's still that one and start
all over again. And I was just,
I guess now that I think about it, I had
a pretty long obsession with statistics.
If you were to give advice to yourself
on a day before ESPN launched,
not necessarily about the next day, but
just any advice whatsoever, would you,
would you give yourself any advice?
I probably would have hoped that we were
a little farther along going on the air.
I W I always want to be the next step.
Um,
and it didn't turn out that the next
step would have been a whole lot better
because everything turned out pretty well.
Are there any pitches that come to
mind that were complete disasters,
complete failures in any,
I certainly can. I mean,
I've had my fair share. I'm just wondering
with regard to ESPN or, or anything,
anything just oh yeah.
Entrepreneurs start,
lots of businesses very convinced
that everything's going to work fine.
I did the,
uh,
radio networks for Massachusetts
University of Massachusetts
and then expand it.
They're doing basketball networks
and hockey that works every time.
I thought they were really
good, somebody to say, well,
we're not going to do that anymore.
And I said, okay. And you know,
that's the way it is. Obviously
you're disappointed. Yeah.
But you can't stop living. It's not the
end of the world. I mean, you keep eating,
that's all there is to it.
And uh, I don't know if it's,
if it's luck,
if it's coincidence,
if it's,
I dunno what,
whenever I've had a moment to
come, uh, we had, uh, we had a,
a home automation company that we bought
into long before all of the technology
could make it really happen.
Not a good idea.
Sounded like a great idea at the
time, but you know, what, we tried,
it didn't work.
Push aside and keep on going.
So you, you've been thought
of as this, for instance,
with the NCAA as sort of not Nostradamus
of college sports, right? Because you,
you got the programming
and then Lo and behold,
we have Larry Bird Magic Johnson. All
of a sudden it's the rage, right? Yeah.
And it seems like, Eh, certainly I've,
I've seen this a lot where
I live in Silicon Valley,
that you've had a lot of great bets,
but some of them,
like the home automation had been early
and you've paddled for the long. Really?
Yeah. How do you, how do you think about
evaluating opportunities like that?
I mean,
you've made plenty of investments as well.
Well, what I would, I think about is
obviously we all think about the success.
I bet if I might think about success
a little bit differently, you know,
we put together a business
plan, right? What's your,
what's your mission statement?
Have you ever seen mission
statements? Sure. Page long three. Oh,
I know what you have. But I mean,
some of them are page long summer,
three paragraphs.
They get beyond 10 or 12 words.
I think we've lost focus ESPN to this day.
You know what their mission statement is?
Six words,
six words drive ESPN to serve
sports fans anytime, anywhere.
That's it. Does that say it
for ESPN or does it, yeah,
if I can't reduce it
to some simple that I can see it.
Let's make it work this way. Um, we're,
we're involved in a new
business. No, sounds funny.
At my age, right? I'm an old,
but I'm not that whole,
I'm not too old.
I want to do things like your brain
works 10 times faster than mine. So yeah,
I have no sympathy,
but this has to do with streaming.
What do I know about streaming?
I didn't know anything about satellites,
but I'll find out.
But I don't have to know about streaming.
You dream it. We streaming. How's that?
Six words. Six words.
Good statement. Good,
good mission statement.
But it really isn't everything
that we all undertake.
If you decide you're going
to go to the movie yet,
the second pick a good movie that you
want to go, say, pick the wrong one,
what do you do? Well, we'll try it
again. Or do you go home and say,
I'm never going to the movies
again because that didn't work.
When you make an investment,
how do you decide how big it
is and do you cap the downside?
Is there a point where you say,
all right, you know what, this,
this isn't where we want it to be.
I'm going to cut my losses.
How do you think through that?
That I think that there, I think you
have to set a threshold, if you will,
that is both upper and lower.
[inaudible] uh,
I always think the sky's the limit
once you have to think at the bottom.
And if it's not going to work,
take your medicine and,
and check out.
That's all I on theirs.
I can't tell you how many things and how
many times, how many cars do you buy.
And then of course when you go into the
day, you buy the car. Oh, you're so,
oh this is perfect. And so what,
and what? Two years later, you know,
maybe you're just slapping
things around the car,
you throw things in the trunk
or something on the front seat,
you don't pay much attention to it.
And then pretty soon you
don't want that car anymore.
You have to get another new car.
So that was gone.
So you cut your losses and you get
rid of that. I want to get to know it.
And that would, life is all about
really what, what's your choice?
What are we going to do in the next hour?
What are we going to do the next day
or the week or the month that follows.
And then I've just been a,
I'm a positive.
I approached life from a positive side.
And when you say it's a loss and how
do you cut your losses? Sure you,
you would rather not do that.
It's not the end of the world.
And part of the education
part of the education.
So when you look at, I mean you've,
you've used your time very well.
I mean clearly putting together ESPN just
to make that series of miracles happen
can't depend on a miracle.
I mean you had some good timing,
but you made a lot of good decisions
when you were at your peak,
when you were just a machine,
what did your days or weeks look like?
How did you manage your time and maybe
the better question is how you do things
differently.
What I would do is every day,
if I had to meet you someplace,
you were on the schedule tomorrow,
you,
you were the next thing
that I was going to do,
but seven other things might come up.
Vinny Twain and I'd have to figure it out,
how to do them and some of my put back
to after you and I really, it sounds fun.
It's funny, it sounds like
maybe I'm at a pinball machine.
I've gone from area to area,
but each one of those stops had
meaning in of some sort. Uh,
back in the soliciting
cable operators time we,
there was a book back then called standard
rate and data service. There was no,
remember that you remember that big book.
We would look up sports directors or
radio or a presence of cable system.
We decided we were just going to
go pitch the top 20 cable systems.
Two of US split. I took the
top first. Then the next
guy, Eddie Egan was his name,
took the next 10 and we had a young lady
sitting in our hallway in our office
that was her office was in the hallway
outside two offices. We only had two
and we had her call each of those cable
operators and say here in Los Angeles
for through was one.
We'd say,
you know bill is going to be in Los
Angeles on Thursday and it would like to
meet with Tim at two o'clock. I
don't know who Tim is, I don't,
I don't even know where your officers,
I'm going to have to get out there and
find a map and find you. We did that.
She called 10 cable system,
the 10 biggest cable session at the time,
all 10 of them for convening
all 10 of them,
so five of them were in Denver and I
just went right down the street and met
with them all and kept him. Those
kinds of things. Don't be a,
don't be afraid to try crazy things.
I mean,
who would have thought
something like that would work?
I'd probably be saying what?
What happens today?
If your cell phone rings and a phone
number says unknown, I don't answer it.
Don't answer. Does anybody answer? Not
me. I had two of those today. Hang Up.
So now here we are calling. You have to
have to do with this way. Put the dial.
That's a long way back.
And, and I, I just think
if you're,
if your intentions are not honorable
and you're not trying to do a good thing
for yourself and the customer,
you shouldn't make the call.
But if you're trying to [inaudible]
so two things I want to point out just
to underscore first is that you had two
offices,
three people,
but you very adeptly gave the
impression of having a larger company,
right? Oh yeah. We were big. We
had this big thing, huge hallway.
And then number two is this gambit of
So-and-so's is going to be in town for two
days.
Can you take the meeting if you had said,
I'm based in La and I'd love to take
the meeting and the next two days never
would have happened. Right. I
don't know why for whatever reason,
this psychological judo
moves just works so well,
but it works for just about everything.
Yeah.
To this day I'm calling from Hartford,
Connecticut.
Good. Then I'm going to or
will Plainville, Connecticut
at the time. DENVER,
Colorado as long way off
Houston, Texas, by the way,
on that swing of 10 yeah.
You've got two customers
so I, okay, so I have a
question. So you're like,
just so happens that a bill
is going to be in Denver,
Colorado next week for
two days when you show up.
Did they ever ask you while
you're in Denver, Colorado?
No.
They knew it because apparently at that
point they would have figured out by
then, but who we were.
Yeah, I do remember though,
visiting TCI and I'm not sure TCI is Iran.
I do remember them.
I don't know if they're still don't.
I Dunno.
I think maybe at and t bought
them at one point. But anyway,
I went in to meet with this
fellow and I hit my 11 law.
Literally when you asked earlier I at
one piece of paper type written 11 lines.
That was my whole pitch.
That was it.
Verse any of these 11 lines.
This is like the holy grail.
Not really, but I mean it was,
we're going to do 24 hour sports,
we're going to do college and et Cetera,
et cetera.
We're going to be financed by Getty.
We're going to be financed.
We didn't say by getting it right,
we expect to be the largest
cable provider to turn her.
Only had 3 million subscribers at that
point. It took us a year to slow. Best.
Damn. Yeah, that was fun.
But I went to an enemy to TCI and this
older gentleman that I was meeting with,
I mean he was my age,
but he was not a rookie and vice
president of something and he had been a
broadcaster in Minneapolis and
he looked across at me and he,
and he kind of smiled and he said, no,
this isn't gonna work. You said, you know,
we both been in as a tip broadcast.
I do know it's going to work.
Cable television. I said, you're working
for TCI. Well, yeah, he said that.
He admitted that we went back and
forth a little bit and he said,
I'm telling you any, he
did just this. He said,
I'm telling you it's not going to work,
but if it does,
I want to be your first customer.
I thought trip to Denver,
it's been a success and he was in
fact the third customer, he didn't,
he didn't make it fast.
Now it could be the first customer.
So a lot of those things
just happen on the spot.
You have to kind of know all of the
general areas you want to go and stay with
it and then at,
and it still works to this day.
This is the first is from Facebook,
from Sid Jacobson.
Why don't they show
Australian rules football,
the world's strongest man and
sticker tournament's anymore.
My favorite part is the
second part of this.
And what happened to this cool jackets?
They're reporters had dual air.
So now that the first part,
I don't know if it,
if it applies perfectly because I have
seen if so many channels now world's
strongest man for instance.
But is there anything that has been that
you got rid of? So you didn't take the,
the rooftop tennis?
No, no. That would never happen.
A Australian rules football is
actually on ESPN Australia. Got It.
All right, so just found
its way home. Yeah.
It's just found its way back there and
not an occasion that will will show there.
There are layers of ESPN, ESPN, the
mothership, that's what they call,
it's like star wars only. It's
ESPN sports, the mothership.
But then it's to a news and you
and Xyz and around the world,
but then they have a Australia and so on.
And as a matter of fact,
it's intriguing. The show
Australia, the national,
the a cricket championship, right.
They sent a crew to Australia,
do a lot of uh,
preproduction a tape,
brought it back and actually produce
the cricket championship from Bristol,
Connecticut while they
were playing in Australia.
And you know how that works with
satellites? I don't have any idea,
but they are an Australian rules.
Football is,
I'll never forget those guys in the
white hats and that was pretty cool.
Never it never understood
it but it was pretty good.
It's a cool sport to for those of you
haven't seen these, these athletes,
a lot of them have accuracy with kicking
that quarterbacks in the u s have with
their,
with their,
no. So it was cool jackets that we used
to have one of the cool jackets you're
talking about the Getty red,
the orange and as soon as possible
and practicable we got it.
No there's shortly after the
check arrived, got rid of the,
the right dead poet's society.
Slash [inaudible] we used to have to
pin little ESPN zone,
those jackets that we didn't have them
embroidery cause we didn't have the
budget. I guess. I don't know why but
wait. All right, well I may have to go
hunt down one of those jackets for myself.
Next question is from Twitter at Neil.
Oh Martin,
I may be saying that incorrectly.
What sports do you wish
were more popular on ESPN?
There's so many.
I mean,
I like college football and I like college
basketball and Major League Baseball,
uh, and I don't know how much
more they can put on. Yeah. Um,
they just put together a new,
190,000 square foot digital center,
new digital center.
And in there they have one studio devoted
to the NFL only it's a half a football
field.
They have rising whatever,
and they have things that flow down and
balconies and stairsteps as you can walk
up on all over. Uh, and that's,
that's pretty impressive.
And I don't know what else they could
do for the NFL besides that. I mean,
they're, they're doing everything except
having Roger Goodell and for breakfast,
I guess on
odd sport or Esoteric sport that
you guys had on in the early days,
did you have a particular favorite?
You know,
we had an amateur boxing series
and I've forgotten what it was,
what the name who was,
but what I remember about it as I was
in the Dallas Airport when they had the
trains underground,
not the way they are now elevated.
And I was getting on a
train and I heard somebody,
I was just stepping through the door and
you know, you stepped through the door,
closes right behind it.
I heard somebody calling me and
we were Bob Arum and Don King,
I'm getting on.
And then somebody said the calling my
name and I looked back and here it is and
he's pounding on the windows
and he wanted to talk to me.
But the train pulled out and before
he ever got back into the discussion,
we signed an agreement with Bob Arum,
some of those crazy things.
And that happened on a train and the
randomness of walking down a tree,
a stairs to get on a tram
to go to another flight.
The guy comes down the door closes,
he lost his program chance. Wow.
Crazy stuff. I mean that's just the
way it was. It's like terrifying.
Slash meets like when Harry met Sally,
it's kind of like a
misconnection don king.
But that boxing series to answer
the question and that was,
that was a really interesting,
a lot of boxers,
no name boxers at that time when a couple
of them I guess did rise through the
ranks. That was kind of fun. I'm
so glad I'm not a boxing fan. Oh,
I am a, I am a huge boxing fan,
but uh, also a huge hurling fan.
So for those of you who haven't seen it,
I definitely recommend checking out
the senior nationals of Irish hurling.
It will blow your mind. It's
like football, meats, Lacrosse,
but they're playing with ax handles and
can hit each other and hit it like a
baseball. It's terrifying. I la,
I had, I was invited to do an,
uh,
an interview in Dublin.
We did via Skype and I agreed to do it
only if the host would explain to me
Irish early,
which he did and I used to describe it
as two guys with baseball bats and the
right hand and left hand betters boxes,
the ball on a tee in the middle
and the somebody reached in,
throws it in the air.
They both take mighty swipes at
it and hope they miss each other.
I'm not so sure.
Sometimes they hope they miss each other,
then they go right after each other.
If you want to see, uh, yeah. What,
what the, uh, the Irish do when they're
not drinking Guinness. And by the way,
the senior nationals are
sponsored by Guinness generally.
So Internet don't go crazy. Uh,
then you should check it out.
It is fantastic. We did have
those, by the way, at one time.
Did you ever see that those early red
jackets that had ESPN and the circle
around it? The original, I
can imagine though. I mean,
knowing what the logo looks like.
Well, it happens in the jacket.
It's one of the greatest
marketing stories.
Espn ahead in the early days. Let's
get into it. We had these red jackets,
little logo on the front,
the, it wasn't ESB network,
it was the ESPN with the lips around it.
And we had the bright red jackets and
in white on the back it had ESPN and the
logo and Scotty Connell said,
we, we were credentialed.
We could go to college football games.
He hired kids and gave him
a notebook and a red jacket,
send them to any game
CBS was doing and said,
I want one of you on the 25 yard line,
one of you on the 50 yard line and one
of you on the other 25 yard line and two
more stay with the line of
scrimmage backfield and offense.
Now if you're familiar with the way of
football game was covered cameras around
the 25 or 30 yard line.
They shoot down field and there's one
high in the middle and then there's
usually some down in the field near the
backfield or the line of scrimmage and
so on.
So every shot that CBS did that first
week had an ESPN logo or product placement
right in, right in the middle of
Monday morning. The phone rang,
we're going to suit you guys, you can't
do that. CanNot do that. Scotty said,
okay, fine. We're CBS planning. Next week.
I did the same thing and after the second
week they called and said, alright,
we surrender.
And so he didn't change very much,
but he cut it down I guess
from five to three either side.
That's about all he did.
Mother advertising that case was the
necessity was the mother of invention and
that one, oh, that's genius. But
those red jackets counted a lot.
I was in the fourth grade that
morning that we had Pearl Harbor,
the day of infamy and I've read the,
uh,
midway and Pearl Harbor and
all of the books around that.
And I have a library of about,
it's probably a hundred to 150 books of,
from the early thirties all the
way through up to the Vietnam War,
Korean War.
Coldest winter is one that
I would recommend a David
Halberstam wrote that one.
Coldest butter. Yeah. And there are just,
I don't know what it is. I really just
enjoy reading it. It's not that I'm,
I'm lucky, obviously I'm lucky that
I'm here and able to do this, but,
uh,
the things that people have done
for us in this country are amazing.
This, this point I think is really
important. So only in the last,
I would say six months have I started
reading more books related to war
specifically in this country.
And one of the main reasons is that,
uh,
spoken with a number of folks,
including former navy seal
commander named Jocko Willink,
is very well known.
And the point that he makes is that
if you want to study human nature,
you can learn,
and I'm paraphrasing of course,
but you can learn so much by looking
at it when it's forced to the extremes,
when you see the most
unbelievable levels of kindness,
the most unbelievable levels of brutality
and everything in stark relief when
you study Warren Warfare.
So if you are a student of human nature,
which of course transcends
this conversation and applies
to just about anything,
that was one of the points that he made.
And just to,
to pull it into say
new media for a second,
if people are wondering if anybody
here knows who Casey Neistat is,
might have a few hands.
He is an extremely well known utuber.
He has hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of millions of views, very,
very well known a filmmaker.
And he says that everything he
learned about business and life,
he learned from studying World War II.
Effectively. It's that powerful. Uh,
when you say that, just people
don't, they think of America.
We're just here.
We won the war.
All our planes were built in the
interior of the country because they were
worried about Japan coming to
the Pacific and in Germany,
the submarines were made in Manitowoc,
Wisconsin.
You think of a submarine,
why would you do a submarine
and that walkway for safety?
Because they had German u boats on
the East Coast and Japanese may be,
they don't know. On the
west coast, like Michigan,
the Naval Air Station in plain view had
an aircraft carrier in Lake Michigan,
and that was where they learned to fly.
That's where they got their wings.
Who knows? It's gotta be
hard to transport. Yeah,
but just think about that.
Lake Michigan is right outside Chicago,
pled will enable it and cleanse your
naval air stations right outside Chicago.
The navy is training in the middle
of the country for two oceans.
Why aren't they in the San Diego area
or Los Angeles or Philadelphia enabled
yards. But you learn, you can
really learn a lot about the,
the, the operation of
life. One thing that I,
and I, every time I've mentioned
this, somebody is surprised.
We always hear about women at work
during World War II and especially in the
aircraft industry and making those
submarines and Manitowoc, Wisconsin,
the majority of the labor force were women
because they were more able to do the
delicate detailed work detail work
and the wiring for the wiring.
Then for radio and for all of those
things with a lot different than right to
today. Well today they wouldn't
wire that would all be,
I'll be at a chip someplace but we
never hear about that. Yup. And uh,
it was an all out effort,
believe me.
So this, this is going to be a bit of a
left turn, but I want to ask you about it.
Your signal, you're signaling
at least left turn strike.
Oh wait, no, I forgot to,
I would be terrible. Empire. I tell
you, even worst baseball player,
but that's a different story.
Your best or one of your best or most
worthwhile investments you've ever made.
And I want to explain what I mean by
that. It could be money, it could be time,
it could be energy, could be anything.
And an example that comes from, uh,
someone I've chatted with
separately is Amelia Boone.
Amelia Boone's a three time a
world's toughest mudder champion.
She's the most decorated obstacle
course racer in the world.
Also a full time attorney at Apple.
She's one of the most
impressive humans I've ever met.
In her answer to that was the entrance
fee for her first major competition,
which was I think about $450.
A huge stretch at the time for her.
But she did it and it produced this
incredible open door and trajectory to
something she never would
have anticipated. What are
one of your best investment?
That $9,000 credit card cash advance?
Yeah.
I have to tell you,
I have to tell you that
brief story about that.
I spoke to a group of um,
Merrill Lynch and I think
it was bank of America,
all senior executives in Greenwich,
Connecticut, some a couple of years ago.
And one of the topics that came up in the
discussion because these banks like to
lend money and you should have bank
loans and start your business and we will
work with you and we'll do you know,
I'm not, I'm not 100% subscriber that.
So when it was my turn to speak, I
get up and I said, well first of all,
you'll all be happy to know that I
started ESPN with bank financing and they
were all sitting, every single one of
them, a tie in pinstripe suits and so on.
I said, well, it depends on how you define
financing. It was a $9,000 credit card,
cash advance. Well, I was talking about
an icebreaker that got me through to them,
but the real thing that got me through
that group was there were a couple of
Hartford whaler from New England whalers
fans in the audience that salvage that
sealed the deal. But to me, he's
a speak to a group like that.
They all,
and I hope I'm not insulting anyone in
the audience watching or sitting here
today.
There is a certain confidence,
a certain bearing and feeling that
people have because they help others down
below them. And as I walked into the
room, I was the oldest guy in the room.
They were all like some of my kids' age.
So they weren't intimidating to me at all.
I just,
we started talking before the meeting was
over there at loosening their ties and
we had just a great, great
session with them. And, uh,
which I think reaching people is part
of what you have to do to win here.
I want to talk,
talk about reaching people in a,
in a very particular instance.
So when you got that cash advance,
$9,000 cash advance on a credit card
where you married or are you saying,
oh yeah. Okay. So now three kids, couple
of them in college doesn't matter.
So in today's dollars, I don't know
what that would be. It's maybe 40 grand.
I'm just pulling a number out.
Yeah, I have no idea. It was that,
was that a lot of money
for you guys at the time?
And was that a conversation
that you've had that,
let me put it in context.
We had a drawer in the kitchen,
a little counter and so on. And the
checkbook was it there? You know,
cause then we wrote, wrote, check, we
didn't have all this internet stuff.
I couldn't pay no bill payer.
Right. And I was writing a check in,
my youngest son walked by me and he said,
is everything all and all,
he was kind of concerned and I was,
cause I hit the checkbook laying
there and we open the checkbook is,
it was just before pay day and
he said that can't be right.
And there were 17 cents
in the bank account,
not in the bank but in the
checkbook. Right. 17 cents.
And he said, are you worried? And I said,
why? He said, well that's not gonna.
You know,
we're not going far.
He was a maybe a junior in college
at that point. But I never,
I never had any doubt because pay day
came and I know something else would
happen. And obviously did what's
your wife were at all? No. Nope.
Nope. Nope. She was, she
was nearly 11 bullet points.
She knew all of it right down the
line yet. She was there for 56 years.
She was there. So it was
okay. That's incredible.
[inaudible]
if we had a golf ball,
how would ask you about golf with
one of this country's presidents?
I was hoping you could maybe
tell us a little bit about golf.
I think it was with George.
Yeah,
George 41 so tell us about,
I think there's one part in particular.
Oh, well yeah, I would, maybe I was
a little irreverent, but, well, yeah,
I was invited to play with President
Bush and a Naples, Florida,
and a, and just a great
guy. We went out and
met the only appropriate people, went
to the driving range, did all that,
had pictures, you know, thousand
pictures taken and so on.
And then we started playing and we
all hit on the green first green and,
and he was maybe, I dunno, three or
four feet from the, from the, uh,
the hole. And he was a
golfer. He used as longs,
the long putter where he put it up
under his Chin and gave the, you know,
putting like this and he kept
swinging back and forth and,
and like, okay, who's going
to give me the Putt? You know,
because I guess you're supposed to.
But,
so after about the fourth
time he stepped back again,
they looked over at us and I,
I don't know why I said,
it's just one of those things I said,
presidential privilege only goes so far.
Putt.
[inaudible] he looked up and he
smiled and he said,
game on.
And so we had a $2 bet for the game
and I had to put this long at the,
on the 18th.
And obviously since he didn't get the
first one you with a bucket and I missed
it and he made his butt and one the
whole and one of the $2 and took the ball
out and said, I want you to have
this in honor of losing $2 to me.
But I don't know why I said that to him.
It was probably inappropriate,
but he cracked up. Seems to have
turned out pretty well when you fly.
Fly by the cuff.
Yeah.
[inaudible]
hey guys, this is Tim again. Just a
few more things before you take off.
Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every Friday that provides a
little morsel of fun before the weekend
and five bullet Friday is a very short
email where I share the coolest things
I've found or that I've been pondering
over the week. That could include
favorite new albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets
and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the uh,
the world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that
I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance.
And it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend.
So if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to a four hour work week.com
that's four hour work week.com all spelled
out and just drop in your email
and you'll get the very next one.
And if you sign up,
I hope you enjoy it.
This episode is brought
to you by four sigmatic,
founded by the genius Fin's who
that the Internet on fire and the,
you may have heard of
their mushroom coffee,
which features Chaga and lion's mane,
which has taken Silicon Valley by storm.
I use it pretty much every day,
either that or the Chaga,
which is decaf and a separate version.
And I use both of these primarily
for focus and productivity.
They just get you going let
you up like a Christmas street,
so he's definitely check it out.
People are always asking me what I use
for cognitive enhancement and for right
now this is the answer. I try to
force this on all of my house guests.
It is a hell of a thing if
I have employees or people
come over who are working
on projects with me,
I always try to feed it to them because
I'm going to get the limitless effect
and get a lot more out of them.
The first time I mentioned this product
and four sigmatic on the podcast,
their products sold out
in less than a week,
so you may want to check them out soon.
If you're listening to this and
the coffee tastes like coffee,
it takes just seconds to prepare with
hot water and oddly enough only includes
40 milligrams of caffeine,
so it has less than half of what you
would get in a regular cup of coffee.
I don't get any jitters, acid reflux
or any stomach burn, any of that.
It's very unusual and very,
very cool.
So if you don't like caffeine,
they also offer very strong,
but caffeine free mushroom elixirs, which
I will sometimes have in the evening.
I find Chaga specifically to be very,
very grounding and earthy.
So that is another option. And I have
a cupboard full of their products, uh,
at the moment, which is right
around the corner of my kitchen.
You can try something,
you can try a sample pack,
which is great also right now by
going to foursigmatic.com/tim that's
foursigmatic, f, O, u,
R s, I g, m a t I c.com,
forward slash Tim and use the Code Tim
Tim to get 20% off your first order and
they're not that expensive. Anyway, if
you are in the experimental mindset,
I do not think you'll be
disappointed to trim up.
This episode is brought
to you by a sense protein.
I am really excited about this discovery.
I became aware of these guys when I
found out that they'd spent five years
trying to manufacture a better
version of weight protein.
And the result is something called native
proteins, which represents cleaner,
purer, less processed protein.
So here's a mini tutorial.
There are only a handful of companies
worldwide that can extract native proteins
directly from mill
traditional whey protein.
What you've probably bought before
is a byproduct of making cheese.
So a company must have the resources,
no hell and a large customer
base to invest in extracting
proteins directly from
the milk without the ability to also
profit from the associated cheese.
That means the net net is native
proteins are super rare. So a sentence,
the only us based company that offers
native proteins both way and my seller
casing directly to a consumer,
they're able to do that because the
parent company Laprino is a huge cheese
manufacturer.
They've been filtering proteins for
more than 30 years and there are a few
important things to take away from this.
Number one,
zero artificial ingredients that is a
solid claim is much stricter than all
natural. Number two, they've
done extensive testing.
So the chocolate which I've been using
after every workout and also in the
mornings because uh,
finalized after 282 recipes were
vetted and perhaps most important,
I talked about less processed.
They avoid steps like leaching and this
is important to understand so it's,
it's a very big deal but hasn't
yet caught on for sports nutrition.
Traditional whey proteins are a byproduct
of cheese making. Like I mentioned,
many of the proteins are therefore
orange in color because they were sourced
from say cheddar cheese production because
companies can't sell orange powders
of Noah or strawberry.
They have to bleach the proteins white.
This harms the proteins and leaves
trace amounts of bleach in the product.
That is no Winham, no good infant
formula companies, for instance,
abandon banned the use of bleach proteins
already in in their products and that
is why a sense parent company,
Leprino foods is the number one supplier
of protein, infinite formula companies.
So all that said, if you want
cleaner, pure, less process protein,
I certainly do and I'm really excited
to be using this protein and I just ran
out of chocolate so I need another
bag. Check it out. Go to a center,
protein.com forward slash Tim,
that's a s,
c e n t protein.com sent protein.com
forward slash Tim and you can receive 20%
off of your entire order and want a
quick 25 gram dose to start your day.
For instance, you're falling
slow carb diet or after workout.
This is a great option. They also have my
cell key scene, which is slower release,
and you can check that out.
So take a look, go to a sense,
protein.com forward slash Kim.